hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast maximizing microscopy output
and cell biology a practical guide to
high content imaging and analysis
presented by dr. Nicholas Dolman PhD we
are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific to learn more about thermo
fisher scientific please visit w ml
fisher com thermo fisher scientific
incorporated is the world leader in
serving science with revenues of 17
billion dollars and approximately 50,000
employees in 50 countries our mission is
to enable our customers to make the
world healthier cleaner and safer we
help our customers accelerate life
sciences research solve complex
analytical challenges improve patient
diagnostics and increase laboratory
productivity through our premier brands
thermo scientific applied biosystems in
vitro jen fisher scientific and unity
lab services we offer an unmatched
combination innovative technologies
purchasing convenience and comprehensive
support I'm Brenda Kelly Kim of ladders
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the broadcast just
click on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many of your questions as time permits
at the end of this presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge this window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
finally if you have any trouble seeing
or viewing hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem now I'd
like to introduce our presenter
dr. Nick Dolman Nick received his PhD
from the department of physiology at the
University of Liverpool and created a
completed a postdoctoral fellowship at
the ni ni h nick has been with thermo
fisher scientific for seven years and is
currently senior staff scientist in
research and development he has led the
development / of / 50 products that
cover a diverse range of technology
platforms including fluorescent protein
based biosensors in vitro jen clickit
chemistry and environmentally sensitive
dies I will now turn the presentation
over to dr. Doleman
thank you all very much for joining us
today I hope you find the following
presentation useful as we start to look
at a few practical considerations for
employing high content imaging and
analysis to look at what we're actually
going to go through today I'm just going
to break the seminar down into a small a
few small parts for you first of all
we're going to look at the advantages of
using high content imaging and analysis
well then actually look at how the
images are acquired and how we do the
analysis this is really where the
advantages of high content imaging and
analysis come in so we're going to spend
a fair amount of time going through this
well then finish off just to show you a
few examples of how we can use my
content imaging and analysis to answer
some very pertinent biological questions
but before we go on let's take a step
back and actually think about why we
might use fluorescence microscopy itself
well for us since microscopy like any
microscope allows you to study a cell
and it's intact setting indeed we can do
live cell imaging and then a cell is
alive and moving around and functioning
as normal while fluorescence gives us
his contrast we get enhanced sensitivity
we can really start to see some of these
structures and functions occurring
within cells with improved resolution
and of course using fluorescence we can
actually tag certain proteins you'd be
using fluorescent proteins or indeed
antibodies and use that to tell where
those proteins are or as markers of
certain structures or indeed certain
processes and because of the properties
of fluorescence we can look at morning
one protein at once so we can look at
more than one structure or more than one
process within their son so we can look
at well as monikers are in space how
that changes over time and indeed what
may be Co localizing with those proteins
so we do see a lot of pros of using for
us since microscopy however some of the
drawbacks in terms of their throughput
and the quantification it can be rather
time-consuming to acquire a lot of
images and then to bring them into
quantification software to derive
numbers because as nice as the pictures
and images we are that we get from the
microscope are without quantification
they're really not much used to us to
answer biological questions
so how do we address those drawbacks of
throughput and quantification well we're
not doing very much different you know
we're starting with essentially a
regular fluorescence microscope however
it does look a little bit different they
tend to package it up in a box okay but
the same thing that you do in the
standard microscope you do with a high
content energy firebox you take an image
however with high content imaging and
analysis we don't just stop at one the
system will then take another field and
another and another so here the
automated acquisition starts to come
into play we're able to gather a large
number of cells from a very very short
imaging protocol of course because we're
using fluorescence we can use multiple
emission filters and get more channels
we're not limited to two or three or
four we can get many and build up a very
in-depth picture of what the spatial and
temporal distribution of molecules are
within cells more often than not we
using multi wall plates these can be
96-well plates or 384-well plate however
it is important to note that we can also
image regular glass bulb in Petra dishes
as well as cover slips and slides
however what Wells within those plates
give you is the ability to do multiple
replicates if you're looking at
concentrations of various compounds or
if you're looking at libraries who are
able to look at a large number of genes
for example in the srna library or a
large number of compounds within a small
molecule I agree let's gives us this
rapid and unbiased acquisition of a
large number of cells and we'll talk a
little bit about why that's important
later on we'll look at the relevant and
robust view of the heterogeneity within
a population as well because you're
sampling such a large number of cells
how do we actually acquire these images
well it's very important to get the
acquisition right because they're the
basis for all the downstream analysis we
start with our acquisition box
essentially we have the ability like a
regular microscope to do a number of
different image acquisition and setups
we can look at different objective
lenses from 4x right up to 60 X and it
depending on what you want to do you
will select different objective lenses
if you need speed you are not so
concerned with subcellular resolution
you can go down to lower my
vacationers as you start to want to
capture and more detailed processes
within the Vinland cells you may want to
go up in objective lens magnification 20
40 or even up to 60 X just like without
with regular microscopes we can acquire
images in whitefield or confocal mode
and of course confocal has a number of
advantages it improves your axial
resolutions we can get crisper images
it's especially important when we're
looking at complex three-dimensional
structures here's a comparison of a
right field and a confocal image an
embryonic body stained with an to be 23
tubulin this is very important we start
to do the segmentation of identification
of objects you can see the improved
object identification with confocal
versus wide field here in this maximum
projection from white filling our
continental image we can also do color
metrics we aren't just limited to
fluorescence imaging either here's an H
and E stained tissue section we've also
Costain romanti body against the
proliferative marker ki67 detecting the
fab when we're asking the software to
segment recognize those ki67 positive
cells within the HD staying tissue so we
aren't just limited to fluorescence
either we can also select a number of
different for us and channels than this
gives you the ability to look at
multiple molecules within the same cells
and just like on regular inverted
systems we can also do time-lapse
imaging here's an example using our food
cell cycle center this is a cell cycle
sensor that changes color as a sales
progress through the cell cycle and
we're able to look at cells over time
depicted on bottoms frame number we can
see their progression through the cell
cycle so we aren't limited to static
images we can do time lapse in the gene
as well when we think about the analysis
is important to consider when we're
actually going to set this up we're
still looking at the same configurations
for a image acquisition but we do need
to think about one ourselves are doing
if we're using fixed out cells or living
cells that have a stable reporter in
them or the processes won't be changing
much over the course of time which will
be acquiring a data we're actually ok to
set up the analysis prior to the scan so
we'll go in and more segments cells
identify objects
actually scanning the plate using just a
few images representative images taken
from your plate however if we're doing
time-lapse imaging or we've got very
sensitive reporters that might be
changing very rapidly what we can do is
actually acquire the images and acquire
only we then go back into a disk scan
this is essentially when we take the
acquired images from our hard disk and
we re analyze them call this a
disk-based scan and it's a way of
speeding up your acquisition times when
we think about the acquisition itself we
essentially have three steps first of
all we just acquire those images and if
we're doing the analysis set up prior to
plates camp but often acquire the
positive and negative control images is
the example of proliferating cells
labeled with our click 'add sa click it
plus edu this tells us which cells are
synthesizing DNA and server in s phase
here we have on the Left control versus
on the right Lee cells being treated
with a mitotic blocker so they have an
exit into cell mitosis and not able to
enter s 8 which is why we don't see any
green nuclei once those images are
required will you put them into the
reference manager essentially we can
compare those min and Max images from
there we can start to build the
segmentation for subsequent analysis we
can do image adjustment here of course
we're limited to linear adjustments and
should never do nonlinear adjustment to
an image but we can improve the
brightness in contrast and we can remove
background to get better identification
of those themselves from there we can
start to do object identification this
is when the software actually picks up
water cell is and the mare can build up
all the subsequent downstream analysis
portions within the cell I show you
examples by and large using nuclear
segmentation and oftentimes we'll use
dyes such as hoechst or Daffy these
admitting the blue channels and they're
very very bright and very good for
cellular segmentation of course you can
label off the whole cell the image on
the top right there and that is an
example where we've used a cell mask and
this labels the whole cell and so we can
better segment entire cell inner area
so once we have those images we've
identified the cells we can then go into
identification in the second channel and
this is the channel and we often input
and contain me the reporter of interest
so here we're looking to identify it
sounds that are positive for clicking
edu which means we're looking at percent
responders the proliferative index and
once we have those cells identified we
can start to look at all sorts of
quantitative parameters we can look at
how the histograms fall for certain
intensities we can look at this spread
as a function of any number of other
cell in the parameters and from there we
can start to gate and say which ones we
want to view as being responders to
counted as positive of course we can
actually visualize all of the cells here
we just have some cells labeled with
Daffy what you see here are
characteristic cell cycle distributions
of DNA dice or I'm just going to get
back to that slide if I may and
highlight those for you here we have our
2n population here we have our foreign
population and here we up here we have
our super for n so we can actually see
that born out with the images we have
greater DNA die concentrations in the
cells in a synthesized DNA prior to
mitosis where these have way more so I'm
not really part of the cell cycle again
we can do this for any number of
different reporters in any channels we
can actually visualize the cells and
then we'll sort of pre-acquisition QC
make sure we're seeing what we think we
should be seen I'm actually going to
show you now an example asset to further
highlight how the software is able to
identify cells and then look at objects
within those cells we're going to use an
assay close to my heart autophagy I see
we're using our cell insight cx-5
high-content screening platform we have
a549 cells or a lung cancer cell line
we've labeled the nuclei with hooks 33
34 2 and this is the reporter that's
going to allow us to identify cells and
then we're looking at autophagosomes
presents with an antibody against the
facts own market lc3 be and will be
picking it up alexa fluor 488 conjugated
secondary antibody
here are the images in their entirety
you can see Herc's channel here lc3 be
staining here and then the overlay on
the right so we're seeing the the
presence of the cells on the left and
then the presence of autophagosomes
within those cells in the middle and how
they overlay together on the right so
once the software is a quiet the image
of the nuclei software will then segment
and say which cells are truly cells
which nuclei sorry truly cells and which
are too small and shouldn't be viewed as
being truly seminar we then acquire an
image in the green channel from the
alexa fluor 488 is of course showing us
autophagosomes from there we then
segment the cells we overlay that
segmentation the circle that's built
from the nuclei with a ring out into the
cytoplasm and from now we're able to
count spots and for autophagy we're
starting to look at spot parameters so
we see the presence of spots in maximal
treated or the absence in minimum
treated we can go through and actually
all the data is already present as you
acquire and so you can look at multiple
different parameters during the
acquisition here we're just looking at
ringspot area in the minimum and maximum
treated these are averages from the
welds but because all the data is
contained within those data sets we can
go back in and actually mine the
responses from every single cell within
that well and you can see the
heterogeneity there some of those cells
with the one micromolar baffle of
meissen do not respond at all and even
in the presence of point one so Michael
nola baffle meissen some sales do
respond so this starts to get to some of
the robust data sets that you're able to
acquire eye contact imaging analysis
because you're able to sample several
thousand cells and really get a good
view of that heterogeneity we can look
at multiple parameters so here we're
just counting the accumulation of rain
spots during the treatment of cells of
battle of Mycenae one this that course
is the accumulation of lc3 b+
autophagosomes within the cell as a
function of concentration we can look at
the area which i previously showed you
we can also look at
30 just going to highlight area for a
moment and show you you don't just have
to be out you don't just have to pull
out individuals sell information from
min and Max you can actually pull it out
the dose-response cast as well so here's
the data from every single cell rain
spot areas the parameter pulled out for
that dose response care we can also plot
it as a 95th and 5th percentile function
as well again we start to see the spread
of those populations laws for generally
shifting them towards having a larger
spot area as a function of concentration
or we can see that heterogeneity this is
an example using spot counts I can also
point you to this reference in the
literature paper from ron's Taylor's
group at pet they're looking at the
heterogeneity of stat3 phosphorylation
are also using high content in Virginia
analysis and it's a very nice piece that
illustrates how we're able to see this
heterogeneous response using high
content imaging analysis and further
states the importance of importance of
this when doing biological research we
don't just have to count spots of course
here's an example using nuclear
translocation we're looking at the
nuclear transportation of nf-kappa B in
response to tnf-alpha treatment the
software builds up a picture of what
cells are truly cells within segments or
ring to cover the cytoplasm and then we
look at the intensity ratio between the
nucleus and cytoplasm to read out neatly
transportation here the six different
colors represent the six replicates
across that plate and of course for
sampling several hundred cells per
replicate sin getting several thousand
sales total concentration so very
statistically robust data sets that were
able to produce in addition to nuclear
translocation or spots we can also look
at the fibers here's an example of a
fiber application using cytoskeletal
organization we've labeled these cells
in relax the floor phalloidin and
treated them recite equation d which
disrupts the actin cytoskeleton a low
concentration on the left we can see has
very little effect and so we can still
see the presence of fibers within these
cells however at higher concentrations
you see the collapse of the cytoskeleton
as a phone as the acting micro fibers
fall apart
we can use a software to take a number
of different readings we can look at the
number of fibers within the cells and we
see that fall as a function of
increasing site oklet's indy
concentration which is what we'd expect
where it disassembling these fibers we
can also look at the mean fiber
intensity and so here we're able to see
those condensation of the fibers into
the small spots then ran out as an
increasing intensity it's a very very
flexible software able to read out a lot
of different parameters within the cell
so for the second part of the
presentation we can look at a few
applications of high content imaging and
analysis we showed you these early but
I'll just summarize which ones were then
to address today look at how we can use
high content imaging and analysis with
cells that have been modified with press
/ and cast 9 genome editing we can look
at some applications of neuronal
differentiation we can look at the use
of antibody drug conjugates in there
read out with high content you can look
at proliferation within populations of
cells and other things that we might
want to use for reparation for and then
finally we will show an example of a
screening application where we've looked
at an SI RNA library so profiling cells
who have had their genomes edited with
Chris Burke ass 9 technology so here
we're essentially looking at cell
profiling and if you look at the
profiling cells we can break this into
two categories is it a targeted screen
or is it a phenotypic screen so what do
we mean by targeted or phenotypic
screening well target has a specific
molecule in mind for example if we're
looking at DNA damage we might look at
the double-stranded break response here
which is sense by ATM and subsequent
molecules and leads phosphorylation of
histone h2ax often referred to as gamma
H 2 gamma faso h2ax here we'd be looking
at the effect of two different compounds
on the phosphorylation of this molecule
and we're reading it out with the sim
responders here this is a very targeted
screening application we know d Zack
protein modification we're interested in
however we may want to take a more
phenotypic approach so we think about
phenotypic screens we're looking at
really a behavior associated with a cell
under certain treatments so if we were
using neurons for example we might look
at excitability this is the example
using our floor bolt a new membrane
potential died that was developed by us
here we can see in blue cells that are
not excitable versus a cell in red which
is so this would be an example of a
phenotypic output excitability or non
excitability when we start to think
about Chris Burke ass 9 editing if you
were to use this genome editing approach
of course you would probably sequence to
confirm that the editing event has
occurred if you are knocking out a gene
you'd also block for the protein to
confirm the protein has been lost but it
is very important to do the accompanying
cellular assays and to highlight this
we're going to show you examples of
targeted phenotypic screen sorry a
targeted screen and as well as a primary
phenotypic screen as well as a secondary
or tertiary phenotypic screen basically
primary phenotypic screens are very
close to the process of interest where a
secondary or tertiary may be further
away again I'm going to go back to one
of my favorites but parts of biology
autophagy and show you an example of
this application using atg5 edited cells
here it made an eighth base pan deletion
in exon 2 on chromosome 6 and we've lost
the protein atg5 atg5 is a very
important protein in the process of
autophagy it's part of the atg5 1216
complex which conjugates the lc3 be
that's been conjugated to phosphate in
denial ethanolamine becoming associated
with the Autofac alone your membrane in
cells lacking or ATT five are not able
to carry out macro ontology so using the
targeted I say we use the RRR antibody
lc3 be which picks up the formation of
autophagosomes we do two different drug
treatments we use chloroquine this works
in a similar manner to battle of Mycenae
one it neutralizes lysosomes so it
causes the accumulation of auto license
within cells we can also stimulate
autophagy with a rapper log here we're
using PB 242 this inhibits and tall it
says stimulates autophagy if you use
these two compounds together you get mad
a tip
so chloroquine causes the accumulation
of lysosomes PP 242 causes the
stimulation of autophagy so together you
get even more spots here we're looking
at ring stop count so we're just
counting the number of autophagosomes
within the cell and we have wild-type
cells these are a haploid cell line as
well as atg5 knockout while we've
knocked out atg5 and what we can see is
that neither chloroquine nor PP 242
normally addition and both together
cause a significant increase in the
number of lc3 be spots in the knockout
cells compared to vehicle-treated
whereas in ran tight we see a
significant entries under all three
conditions so from this we can conclude
that the targeted ass has been
successful we'd can turn confirmed that
macroautophagy is lost under these
conditions so we have a good model
selling the model to study your
targeting we can then take a step back
but do a proximal assay so one of the
functions of macroautophagy is the
clearance of long-lived proteins here
we're using another cliq assay this uses
Homolka project lysine HPG this is an
Athenian analog so one can think of it
as being analogous to an s 35 mad by an
impulse if we incubate cells in the
presence of h PG and then chase out for
a long period of time typically between
24 to 48 hours we're able to look at
those the clearance of those proteins by
a macro autophagy using the readout from
the alexa fluor 488 great signal we use
cleric winds and block the long live
protein degradation and we can see the
battery in these cells despite lacking
macroautophagy have been able to
compensate rather well and are able to
clear long lean proteins just as well as
their wild-type match interestingly we
can also look at the change in lysosomal
mass one thing to notice with these
haploid cells we have very little
lysosomal staining at rest that
lysosomal staining increases upon
blockade of mac autophagy mcclure
occurred which disrupts lysosomal
function the increase in lysosomal
masses is a well known phenomena however
the increase is slightly lower in the
knockout cells than in the wild-type to
hear a few examples of using I content
imaging to do a proximal phenotypic sa
we can also take a step back into a more
distal assay so these cells of loss atg5
and I've shown impaired ability to
induce macroautophagy we can then look
at other cellular processes here we're
using a nucleic acid egg it's click over
project promicin or OPP this is a
protein synthesis essay OPP is a click
modify pure myosin molecule para meissen
resembles an amino satellite to transfer
RNA and so cells are synthesizing
protein they'll incorporate the opp
within fix permit applies the cells the
cliq reaction to attach an alexa fluor
488 to the opp and now as a function of
alexa fluor 488 fluorescence we can tell
how much protein synthesis is occurring
in these cells our cells lost the
ability to clear proteins or had any
impairment in their ability and night
shut down protein synthesis or at least
reduce it however we can see with the
wild-type and the knockout there's no
significant difference in the protein
synthesis between the wrong time andrew
knockout cells so this is an example of
more distal phenotypic assays we can
look at other related events so macro
toph which is a primarily pro survival
mechanism and so one could hypothesize
that if you were to lose macroalgae
maybe you might produce those these
cells to cell death following cytotoxic
stresses here we have a dose-response
staris porn which induces apoptosis we
read out the induction of apoptosis with
our fluorogenic apoptotic probes
sullivan casbah 37 this contains a
nucleic acid binding die attach to DVD
when castes 37 is activated it will
cleave that DVD consensus sequence
leading the DNA die free to buy into
nucleic acids and so it becomes
fluorescent and the signal increases as
apoptosis is induced what you can see is
there's no significant difference
between the induction of apoptosis in
wild-type or knockout cells so these
cells have been able to compensate for a
loss of pro survival mechanism and then
not more prone to to die following
cytotoxic stress you can look at even
even moral distal processes just
proliferation itself on these cells
stressed if they stop proliferating on
the exit of the cell cycle this uses our
click
in the USA that will show in a few
slides along but essentially what we see
here is there's no difference in the
proliferative index between the right
type and the knockout cells and so we
can say that although we've been able to
very surgically edit these cells genomes
and impair macroautophagy they aren't
showing any impaired proliferative index
so lets you look at the use of high
content imaging in neuronal
differentiation one place which high
content imaging is especially important
is actually q seeing the cells
themselves the use of pluripotent stem
cells is a very good way of getting more
relevant or disease relevant primary
neurons the various models of human
diseases and so what we can do is we can
use high content imaging to actually QC
and look for markers and various stages
of differentiation from that pluripotent
stem self-phase to mature and neurons
how we're doing this here we're actually
using some of the Shelf kits we're using
our dopaminergic neuron differentiation
kit where you also using our own
immunized cytochemistry kit as well as
our essential eight medium which is used
in stem cell cultures and then we're
actually doing the cell identification
itself with our cx-5 high-content
screening platform so when we take those
pluripotent stem cells the first phase
which they undergo is the formation of
these floorplate progenitor cells or
FPPs is the precursor of mature
dopaminergic neurons we look for two
markers box a 2 and 0 TX 2 we use target
identification or activation modules to
look to the presence of these markers
and were able to a very high throughput
and objective manner quantify how many
cells within that stem cell population
have become floor / 8th floor plate
progenitor cells following the formation
of floor great progenitor cells were
able to then differentiate these cells
into mature dopaminergic neurons and
here we're looking at the same target
activation monarchic modules the
presence or absence of tyrosine
hydroxylase indicated here with th as a
marker that the cells are fully mature
dopaminergic neurons so again we're
doing this in a very high throughput
manner and very objective
away now I'm going to show you some data
using antibody drug conjugates so why do
we use antibody drug conjugates the way
of very precisely bringing toxic agents
to specific cell types an example is in
cancer where a certain extracellular
epitope is able to be recognized by a
therapeutic antibody and to do that it
brings in an in an anti-cancer agent
which then kills the tumor oftentimes
those agents are endocytosis and traffic
signal rises own within the lysosome the
toxin can then be activated and is
released out of the lysosome and free to
act and they're often microtubule
disrupting agent inhibit mitotic exit
which causes the downstream activation
of apoptosis example I'm going to show
you today uses a new technology that
we've developed called site click it's a
way of site specifically modifying
antibodies and in this case of
therapeutic antibody Herceptin the sugar
molecules on the conserved region 0
modified and then using a strained
alkyne and daibo molecule we're able to
in a very controlled and site-specific
manner label these antibodies we can
label them reliance and we can label
them atop sins and indeed we can do it
by functional label when we put a die
and the toxin and indeed that's the
example I'm going to show you today a
septum is able to buy into her2 positive
tumors and these these are breast cancer
tumors and on the top here we have a
her2-positive cell line esk BR threes
and on the bottom we have md a and B 231
these are her two negative the reception
here has been labeled with the
fluorescent reporter alexa fluor 647 as
well as the microtubule disrupting agent
mmae so we can image them and we can see
that her septum is only binding to her
to positive cells that not her to
negative we can then look at the
internalization as a function of
antibody concentration and perhaps
unsurprisingly the higher concentration
of antibody the more antibody we see
internalizing within the cells because
we're using fluorescence we can be
multiplex analysis and we're able to
look at the subsequent downstream
activation of caspases here we using
Sullivan casts page 37 detection reagent
you can see that the induction of
apoptosis following treatment of these
cells with perceptive and nae of course
this response spoke internalization and
induction of apoptosis is missing from
the her2 negative cells confirming the
specificity of this labeling approach so
proliferation I've shown you a little
bit of data using clicker DD you before
but just to go into how this actually
works the final de redeem is a thymidine
analogue so cell synthesizing DNA will
incorporate edu in the place of
thymidine and then following labeling we
fix permeate lines and subjective sales
to a click reaction and here we can
label those cells with the die until
which ones are in s-phase here we have
an example of our zip code primary
dermal fibroblasts cells labeled with
edu and counterstained atlanta to blend
the edu is suitor colored orange we can
see all those cells of an orange nuclei
are ones that are proliferating we can
show that this is specific for example
we're able to knock out kinesin
molecular motor kiev 11 is involved in
mitotic exit if we knock this down using
rnai we're able to impair the
incorporation of edu because we're
getting fewer cells able to exit mitosis
and then enter s-phase afterwards so
again this is a specific label floor
proliferation speedy is a very useful
tool here which are showing a dose
response curve with tax or well-known
microtubule disrupting agent it
stabilizes microtubules blocks mitotic
exit and as we would expect with higher
and higher concentrations we get fewer
for yourselves Eckstein mitosis so if
you're in furor are able to incorporate
edu as the interests face this is very
important for things like cancer
therapies where we're looking at
blocking proliferation we can use
proliferation for a number of other
readouts as well we can use it as the
base to start building a more in-depth
picture of a population of cells so here
we have s-phase cells as well as a
marker for g2m presence here we using
phosphorylated histone 3 as a marker of
cells there in GT mm what we can do is
start to build up almost flow cytometry
type plots of cellular populations again
because we're sampling thousands of
cells we can do a number of different
drug treatments for the colon that
blocks or sales in g1 s on the corazon
locsin in GT then we can start to gate
and show cells are in g1 phase those
through in s phase those are in g2 and
those are the g1s blocked all those the
g2 NY so again these are plots and you'd
likely see it's like cytometry but now
we're able to read out Marcus than to
depend on their spatial localization we
can also use proliferation as a
sensitive readout for pre lethal
toxicity and what we'll do here is pair
are clicking edu technology with markers
of viability so how these work are
living cells are not not permeable to to
nucleic acid dyes that can't cross a
plasma membrane this is because the
plasma membrane is intact in living
cells those cells will also have a
certain plethora of index and so they
will have a certain number of cells of
labeling up positive for click 'add edu
however its cells are dead they won't be
proliferating and they will now be able
to be labeled with these impermeable
nucleic acid diets I show you an example
here using our viability market imager
dead green as well as click it plus edu
alexa fluor 647 we use camptothecin a
cytotoxic agent and we use a low dose
about 3 micro molar and a high dose now
both of these concentrations would cause
significant cell death which will be
read out with a high readout from the
image a degree if we were to incubate
for long periods of time however this is
a very short incubation period about 30
minutes to 45 minutes and what we're
actually seeing here is although the
cells haven't had much time to die you
can see there's very very few dead cells
and no difference between their 3 and 10
microm are right you can see it is a
very robust shutdown of proliferation
this is a readout of pre lethal toxicity
cells haven't died however they're
telling us that all is not well we can
also combine proliferative assays such
as click etbu with reporters of upstream
signaling this is an example using a gfp
stable I'm this expresses a GFP chimera
of the forkhead transcription factor
forkhead transcription factor
translocates to nucleus and regulate
cell cycle progression
so now we can look at the cytoplasmic or
nuclear localization of the GFP along
with the presence or absence of edu
incorporation for chemically
transportation is dependent on pi3
kinase signaling we can use lower high
doses of wortmannin of pi/3 kinase
inhibitor forever arousing the short
incubation period of an hour on top or a
longer overnight treatment for 24 hours
along the bottom panel we can look at
the differences of a loss of nuclear
translocation with wortmannin treatment
we can also look at changes in
proliferative index as we start to
affect signaling pathways that regulate
proliferation so finally we're going to
show an application screening an example
shows an SI RNA library a few notes
about library screening these generally
will involve a lot of different
molecules or compounds or jeans and so
for this you will require multiple
plates probably to cover the library as
I say there can be a small molecule
library pharmacologically active
compounds or they can be genes for
things like srna shrna or indeed crisper
libraries plate automation can really
help here to handle those plates not
only in the labeling but also been
feeding them into the system and so
things like our orbiter microplate move
are particularly useful to get those
plates into the Machine scanned and back
out we use a barcode technology so the
machine can actually recognize what
plate is blush and we can line up plate
IDs with compound IDs so this srna
library we have srna against every
kinase in the genome also a chi known
we're looking at a phenotypic assay here
at your slightest gleeful rearrangement
so our software is able to segment the
cells look at nuclear size as well a
cytoplasmic area able to accurately
segment EF actin cytoskeleton as well as
the microtubule cytoskeleton what we're
doing here is looking at changes and
disruption of their cytoskeleton we're
actually able to group these into
conserved responses we can look at which
genes produce the same response of the
cytoskeleton from that we can do a
cluster analysis and annotate conserve
responses with different genes so we can
start to tease out where these these
genes may be acting in certain cellular
pathways and how those impinge
on the cytoskeleton so just to finish
off I'm going to bring it all together
and show you how we can provide you with
all of the components of a successful I
content in a gene analysis experiment
within our software we have a number of
predetermined assays that allow you to
do out-of-the-box I content imaging an
analysis experiments as well as ability
to build your own or just acquire only
and come back and scan later we also
have web-based resources that will point
me towards the right reagents to use for
a number of different biological assay
areas so we're able to provide support
not only in the software and hardware as
well as the reagents and we have a
number of online tutorials have actually
helped you understand the fundamentals
of fluorescence which will further
enhance your assay using high content
imaging and analysis we do have a number
of high content systems available we
have our entry system the bench level
cx-5 we have our brand new cx-7 and this
contains laser autofocus as well as
7-channel detection as well as a race
cam and HTS system this is a very
flexible system that can be equipped
with lifecell chambers kinetic imaging
liquid handling as well as confocal
units which are present on the cx-7
system as well in addition to our high
content systems we also have our
accompanying instrumentation such as our
count s cell counter once better than I
wasn't able to go into a lot of detail
as the importance of getting good
plating densities when doing your assets
instead of using system such as the
countess absolutely imperative to make
sure your plating at the right density
as well as our line at bench drop for us
since microscopes which can allow you to
the quick QC checks or indeed in the
case of our FL auto fully automated
plate scans as well so hopefully today
I've shown you what high content imaging
and analysis really is I hope I've shown
you a few compelling reasons as to why
you should consider incorporating high
content imaging and analysis into your
experimental workflow shown you a few
examples of the use of high content
imaging analysis as well as just
summarized a complete offering available
from thermo fisher scientific with
respect to a high content imaging and
analysis so with that thank you very
much for attending today's webinar and I
hope you found it useful
we'll open it up for questions
thank you dr. Doleman for bringing that
important information to us excellent
presentation it's time for our QA as you
said if you have a question like to do
so please ask it now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and hit the send button will
answer many of your questions today as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question you showed a
segmentation of nuclei and cellular area
but how can you say meant live cells yes
sir that's a great question and
primarily the tools I showed you today
were for fig cells so our soul mask
tools are only able to work and fix
those certain nucleic acid dyes such as
hurts 33 34 2 are permeable to living
cells and so they're a useful tool the
nucleus segmentation in living cells if
you were to try and segment for example
cytoplasmic regions within living cells
and you can use dyes such as our cell
tracker and so track a green so tracker
orange as well as a brand new cell
tracker so I'll track a deep red and
these are able to give you good deeper
demarcation of the entire cytoplasmic
area of a cell
great thank you we do have another
question for you dr. Doleman an attendee
asks do you have anything for segmenting
the plasma membrane oh yeah another
segmentation question yeah and we do we
have some tools called cell mass plasma
membrane labels and they're able to to
label the plasma membrane we have a
green and orange and a deep red so
probes emitting in the Fitz egfp range
the tricksy side three as well as the
sci-fi part of the spectrum these are
actually labeled a you use them to label
my cells and however it's that they are
near their internalized fairly rapidly
and so you have a relatively short
window to image the plasma membrane so
we do recommend fixing the cells to
maintain the fidelity of the plasma
membrane level and unfortunately they do
not withstand per mobilization with
detergents and so they're not compatible
of antibody staining
okay we do have another question in
addition to spots and fibers what other
structures can be recognized for
analysis okay yeah we try to show you
the main areas during today's webinar
which is essentially spots fibers or
indeed and looking at translocation from
the cytoplasm in the nucleus fibers are
a little bit of an exception although
they are built out in the software from
the same basic principles but spots
really can be used to segment any
different structure obviously things
like autophagosomes and endosomes and
Rice's ohms are fairly circular and so
they can be trick or two spots and
however if you think about looking at
protein aggregates or indeed
mitochondria things that aren't truly
circular we're still using the same spot
function it's just they might be truly
circular so essentially picking up any
event within a cell of any known
distribution or orientation or
dimensions really will use those circles
though for the nucleus the ring for the
cytoplasm and then using a spot type
function to pick it up so although we
really just referred to more circular
spots are you're able to do a number of
different assays using spot algorithms
that are slightly elongated in one axis
or another
okay thank you I'm afraid that is all
the time we have now for our questions I
just want to pass it back to dr. Doleman
to see if he has any final comments or
suggestions advice for our audience
today I just like to thank you all for
attending today's webinar and I do hope
you found it useful if you do need
additional information you can find it
on thermo fisher com /h CS all of the
information we covered here is available
there as well as a lot more information
in our systems and reagents Thank You
Nick excellent presentation today thank
you for bringing that information to us
and taking time to be with us today here
I also want to thank our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational web cast as possible before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2016 you'll be receiving an email from
lab roots to let you know when this
webcast is available for replay and we
would invite you to share that email
with any colleagues who might have
missed today's live broadcast that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope we see you again soon goodbye